what was it about this script that when
it came to you you said yes I want to
take this on there's a lot of answers to
that I think there's a tonal thing that
I'm really looking for this kind of dark
humor talking about difficult subjects
and a way into this genre of thriller or
supernatural thriller that I really
really enjoy some of the visit split and
glass it all has that kind of weird my
supposed to laugh at this I'm not sure
and it this had that Toni's writing had
that and then the base premise of a
woman who's dealing with her tragedy
through this therapy of pretending this
doll is real was so compelling for me
and I thought wow that's I could I could
tell that story for a long time now
you're known for making cameos in your
projects and I think I caught it in
episode one you did how do you decide
which scene you want to be in in is
there significance behind this the Cameo
you choose this a practical thing
component to it that's tricky which is
it in a movie it you literally can pull
the audience out so if I come in in the
wrong way at the wrong times they all
react or at least half the audience will
react and verbally right there so you
have to be careful you don't break the
kind of suspension of disbelief because
and that can happen with any celebrity
that you use at the wrong time in a
story but in me in particular they're
kind of looking and there's a little
awaiting for when it's gonna happen so
they go there he is and then everybody
starts talking enough and then the other
half to get startled and well what
that's the writer/director
and you're kind of the plots gone so it
kind of has to have certain parameters
when to when's that moment gonna happen
where the audience kind of was letting
on it does it does it derail from the
story is it can you do with a sense of
humor those kind of things what I found
almost jarring about it was the way in
which it was shot you're not breaking a
4th wall because they're not talking to
an audience but they're making eye
contact with you yeah why did you choose
in when you were directing the first and
last episode to use that method I I
really loved its intensity what ends up
happening is your eye line it makes you
feel more and more intense so if I'm if
I'm like there's the camera and if I'm
looking at you there
sensing a little bit of emotion but as I
keep getting closer you're seeing more
and more intensity until I'm staring at
it it's almost disarming because now
they're looking at you and that that
intensity they use of a very specific
scenes not certainly not pervasive
through the piece but it's meant to do
that it's neon-colored emotion and and
it's very uncomfortable and oftentimes I
like that kind of proscenium framing
where you're dead center and it's
everything is balanced perfectly it's
unnerving when you when you have those
kind of framings I don't want you to be
comfortable I guess is what I'm saying
in Philadelphia your hometown why do you
draw so much inspiration from
Philadelphia sorry not your hometown
where you I'm a great knit front well I
feel you know if the story is
appropriate I'm going to put it there if
I'm doing a their stories that I come up
with that I can't shoot that like if I
was making a movie about the Yeti
or something I can't shoot that in
Philadelphia but anything barring that
if it was not in a spaceship or
something like that I want to shoot it's
actually spaceship I could shoot photo
of you I could build it on us on a
soundstage
I love it to be in the hometown because
it gives it this veracity and it gives
it those colors those little quirks and
you don't even know where they're gonna
what they're eating how they're talking
you know what they walk by and you start
to feel a little bit of it wow this
could be true and for whatever reason
Pennsylvania just feels like a perfect
location for bad supernatural stuff to
happen to people it's great